hey
what's going on not much my buddy riley
how have you been i've been uh you know
world class
uh
you know starting off a world-class
report
this is going to be a
top of the line podcast
um yeah we haven't uh
been uh seen each other in podcast form
in a while
yeah we've spent some time consciously
uncoupling
um
and uh
how are things treating you in your van
things are very mobile
uh my uh sink
pipe is keeps on i'm coming
becoming undone so i need to put that in
there tape it up
wow adhesive
um
i can't believe i forgot you had a sink
in your van
yeah you're like uh you know i don't
need to wash my hands i can just do it
in my car
yeah
i gotta cut my car to washington you
have a sink i have wet wipes like that's
uh
yeah i'm more advanced than you even
though you live in a home
um i live in a mobile home
i live in a pee home i live in a mobile
home in mobile alabama alabama
every home in mobile alabama is a mobile
home yeah
uh and so
do you trust
uh that you know
do you trust in texas
um not really
i mean if there's another winter freeze
i think that we did texas didn't improve
any of it i think it would just
go to [ __ ] that's why i have a generator
i was talking to someone at work today
and he was like during the freeze like
he had to
luckily had a fireplace in his house and
he like put blankets on all of the walls
and like his family just stayed in the
living room for like four days in like
40 degree
[ __ ]
weather nice
and uh
i was like
you know that sounds like pretty bad but
that also sounds like kind of fun
yeah i mean that way you can use your
home to its full effect like i always
liked when um
you know there was like a hurricane or
like
uh something where you know it needed us
to stay inside or like or when like the
power went out and we would like get
candles and like you know play
board games and you know
yeah deuce you know
get creative with our space yeah because
then you're hanging out with your family
and it's not forced i mean it is forced
but it's not forced by human yeah
selfishness it's like an escape room or
it's like a
i don't know it's like your house
becomes a different house
yeah
it's more practical
um yeah it's just like we're all in it
together you know we're all getting
through this together let's like find
commonality and yeah
then getting along with your family is
for survival you're like we i have to
endure your annoying jokes yeah that's
probably why like more families stuck
together
you know
and throughout history because it's just
like
you kind of like survived more with each
other now it's just like
like my family like we grew up like like
a lot of times
we would be in our
own rooms watching our own tv show
yeah our own computers
and it's just like we're not we're just
living in the same house together we're
not like really part of a tribe
yeah you don't need to stick together to
survive so you don't but if you had to
stick together then you'd learn how to
get along with each other but you never
had to so you're like well i don't have
to yeah to survive i'm fine
so there's no need to survive with your
family you're like whatever
i'll figure it out when i have to yeah
and yeah it's just like people get mad
at their families like people hate their
families dude like they're like
there's so much drama and
it's like
a lot of the time like
like siblings and like parents will have
like not that much in common
yeah like we grow apart because we have
the technology to be able to go in
separate universes
um
yeah right we have like we can learn i
mean it's just also it's like like we're
different people like people learn in
different ways
like i'll pay attention to
something while another kid pays
attention to another thing yeah
and then that just like
you know trickles up yeah into like a
completely different person
and then you can't get along
yeah um
and it's also just like relationships
like
long relationships there's so much
seated in those
where it's like
it's like we may we may you know
be on the same page right now but like
there's like this entire history of our
relationship with all these fights
and
wrongs and you know all this just like
complicated [ __ ] that it's just like
that like sticks you know yeah that like
that doesn't go away
yeah hopefully it's a good thing like
maybe you're building on top of building
and it's a great foundation and you're
creating something awesome
or maybe if it's like bad and it's like
a shitty thing and then this other
shitty thing accentuates it and then
it's just yeah
psychology and eventually like it can be
ruined like they're like it's very
possible to just completely ruin a
relationship you'll see it all the time
with like parents [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
it's like this arm is working out
um
yeah but
you know
arms uh are known to fail
you know a lot of people have broken
arms
arms are like
they're easy to come off you know a lot
easier probably than a leg
or it's like in your body you know your
body
your upper body doesn't really have
doesn't really can't come off that
easily but your arm
is like so like circular
and
it's
um
just really snappable like people who
dislocate their arms are it's like they
do it like very easily hello
yeah
because they're all out there they can't
get caught in combines or knives and
yeah there's like when you're going
like on a roller coaster
[Laughter]
that's too hard yeah
and then you go back and you're like
we shouldn't have gone back we should
have just talked with the
1i5
is that your arm talking
your arm
that's me help my arm
and my arm but uh yeah i mean i think uh
our arms are
arms are very vulnerable
and they're very useful they're almost
as useful as they are vulnerable
i'd say i'd rather have arms and legs
i'd say
yeah
well there's
my grandma used to say if you have legs
you can go everywhere but you can't do
anything but if you have arms and no
legs and
you can't go anywhere but you can do
everything
right look at stephen hawking
all he did he he didn't even need
anything but a [ __ ] finger
he didn't even need an arm he just
needed a one finger i needed a raymond
cabrera
just a little
and then he just [ __ ]
knew did everything
one finger
what a smart move to get into
astrophysics
yeah yeah because uh if he you know was
if you like [ __ ] worked at wendy's
you know nobody would he would die
he dies so quick you need arms for that
you need people to like you and money
to be
successfully disabled yeah it takes a
lot of work
like
because if you're poor and disabled
you're just
sad and disabled and you're like you're
actually disabled like you you probably
can't leave the house down you're
financially disabled you're
sexually disabled i'm financially a
quadriplegic stephen hockey still
probably got laid like they probably
like
you know stint
stunted
you know put it in a sling yeah like
they probably you know figured out a way
for him to [ __ ]
yeah i'm sure
he was [ __ ] i think he cheated
one finger his favorite chicks
yeah
he's just like moves away from the
keyboard just like onto a clip
he's like controlling her he's like
controlling her
he's like making her let's say stuff
it's like ratatouille
except with a clitoris
he's like uh
he's like okay this is my new
uh voice speaker that's like actually
human voice
not that [ __ ] annoying
what was that even voice was that a
man's voice yeah
welcome to the internet
but yeah he had an american accent on
his
oh he's british right yeah
and they were like why do you have an
american accent
it'd be funny if he just like made it a
black guy
yo
this science [ __ ] bro it's like that's
is that how are you talking before
[ __ ] he's like yeah this is how i
talked before
yo one of it check out this black hole
talking about my [ __ ]
we be looking at black holes in here
not just talking about your wife [ __ ]
oh man
uh yeah i mean
he uh
he's definitely a [ __ ] gangster
dude i wonder if that hurts like being
that not being able to move like that i
bet he had bed sores and like what if
you know like when you're like trapped
and you just want to move you just be
like oh
like that right yeah he probably had
that all the time
like i could really just stretch
i've been sitting too long sitting is
the new smoking
and i feel like i've been smoking a pack
i just can't move
because like if you move all your blood
vessels
activate and then
your body actually like releases
hormones based on your movement so if
you're not moving then your body isn't
doing a lot of the [ __ ]
because it's tied to
your movement it's like oh we don't have
to pump our own blood we can just wait
until he has to go to the bathroom oh
yeah true
so he's he's his body's just learned
i bet your body is
limp penis
yeah
you can't you can't get a boner
and his wife like stuck with him right
yeah and then he cheated on her dude
with his nurse
[ __ ] savage man like he's like
just disgusting looking and you're still
like getting chicks he's famous
um
yeah but famous for like some dirty
science [ __ ]
for progressing our species what did he
do
he
like came up with some formulas around
black holes or he like discovered black
holes or something
uh
okay
where's the black hole i haven't seen
one
this is i mean he's he's probably just
making that up
i mean maybe like
let us learn more about our universe and
what's going on in it
and it illuminated
the darkest part of our universe whoa
i mean um
a black hole you know
it's not that bad
yeah i mean
arms
legs
bodies who do you think has the sexiest
body
uh atoms of your
personal preferences
what do you mean like men or women
um
i think that
women
definitely naturally
have a sexier body but men can get like
muscles
yeah like when women get muscles it's
not as sexy but like men have the
ability to like
deck out each individual part of their
body like women's just like the body in
general is just like wow
like men is just like whoa
yeah check out this room and then i got
this room it's like their body's like an
mtv crib it's just like
over here i got this muscle i actually
got this muscle from you know like my
tour in afghanistan and you know it's
just like
yeah like if you like male bodies that
must be the best because you can just
like
multiply it by a thousand yeah but girls
bodies are pretty much
like once you got it perfect
you just have to not [ __ ] it up yeah you
just have to not eat
okay
you gotta
maintain the volume to surface area
ratio
um and it's funny that
that's like our attractiveness it's just
like
we're attracted to the weak
weaker the
better i think weakness is just a
correlation
and
we're attracted to graceful
beauty symmetry
and
you know
just like
divinity of the human female
it's like all in line it's like a
like the shape and curves and all that
like the
[Music]
yeah
weakness
i tried not staring at women as much or
i've decided to just now because before
i've just now yeah
just theoretically
i probably shouldn't be staring at women
oh what do you mean you like how do you
stare at women like when i'm driving and
there's an attractive lady i'll be like
yeah you do a double take yeah
like i it's like so crazy because i'm
not getting
anything out of it like there's nothing
logically or logistically my life isn't
approved by it but like
just seeing a beautiful woman it does
so much to me it's like a little hit
it's a work of art yeah
um i think you know
it's uh
you're just appreciating beauty
but it's also like creepy you know it's
like uh i kind of want her to see me
but
that way she'll be like oh
maybe something i think she'll be like
that
but without like i know [ __ ] weird
guy
so with that
uh potential for something to happen
it's not the same i want to do what are
you gonna do pull
over hey
notice you walking hey can i jog with
you
um
yeah i mean i don't think i think that
would
not work most of the time yeah but it's
just for me
it's like very selfish that i want to
exist i want her to be like oh this guy
exists in the world because she's making
such a big impact on me well i mean she
knows you exist she knows
she is
she knows that
people
that people will be scared
she knows that men
exist men exist
we've made our presence known to her
over the years
we sent we sent her a letter we are here
we are looking at you
but uh
i mean yeah it's like it's pretty rough
you know
um
it's uh
it's not polite for sure
yeah but it's so it's just like you see
something beautiful and like you're
you're inclined to look at it anything
you know a cloud
you know piece of art a bunny
yeah
i want to stare at bunnies
a bunny you see a bunny and you're like
wow you know
even i've seen a lot of bunnies but like
every time i see them oh my god the dog
is about to kick over the laptop let me
make sure the camera is getting you
because
every time i see a bunny it's better
than the last time i saw a bunny
was it not on me
and uh
and bunnies are so good they're so
fluffy and they hop around they can go
so fast with just hopping
which i could never do
that's all they do they don't have legs
like dogs do they don't like do the
tooth thing they do you know one hop a
bunny up
yeah i don't know and so i'll take your
word for it
what that's it that's what they do they
hop yeah
okay you not heard that bunny's hop
i think like once they start running
they start galloping like a horse
they just bounce really high
or they bounce
yeah
like yeah i think that i think they do
they do it they're good at it
kangaroos do it
yeah
kangaroo is just a
a
much bigger bunny
[Laughter]
can you imagine seeing a kangaroo
sprinting at you
dude they're so scared aren't they like
six feet tall yeah that's insane bro
that's crazy
they are [ __ ] scary they saw a deer
if they're like standing on their legs
like a deer is just six feet tall but
like horizontal is it six i thought it
was like
four or four feet five feet but if you
add their legs like their torsos are the
same oh yeah but like they're not
towering over you like
like standing up
yeah they're more low to the ground
they're more foreign because they
they
are horizontal not vertical kangaroos
are vertical so it's just like what are
you yeah it's like a human
it's like i feel like i can
do business with you but
you're also first you're also
don't understand me
dude i saw that kangaroo video where
this guy's fighting a kangaroo and the
referee was like
going up to the kangaroo and being like
you got you gotta fight fair okay and
then you like slap the kangaroo whoa and
the kangaroo would hit him back he's
like you can't do that you can't hit me
okay and he like pushed the kangaroo and
the kangaroo would put it's like what
the [ __ ] is up with this ref the ref was
super annoying what the [ __ ] is a
kangaroo fighting league
okay
right like in the 30s or some [ __ ]
um
it's just like so gross that's what
humans are it's just like we use
whatever
sneaky little power that we have to [ __ ]
with things that are bigger and better
than us
and it's just like so gross we love
we love taking our power out
on things
on winter storms in texas
um
yeah i mean
animals
it sucks that animals like aren't that
smart because
we could do we could work with a lot we
could work a lot with animals we could
really use them
like bears i feel like bears and and us
could really get some stuff done
we could collaborate we could put out a
sick new mixtape
[Music]
really do some serious business
i mean um
i mean yeah we can work with animals
you know by naturally
providing them like some sort of like we
can like make our cities green and like
have animals like
you know pollinate and you know pick up
our truck [ __ ] yeah like take care of
[ __ ] i don't know we could give animals
rides if they needed to get animals
could give us rides for food on them
i mean we have horses for that
we have some animals that we picked and
choose to to work with us yeah
and some animals got left in the dust
yeah it's a lot about attitude like a
lot of animals yeah it's like whatever
animals you know attitudes whatever
animals were like always up for the job
you know like
um you know like showing that they care
putting in the
team spirit you know staying late
coming early yeah you know
really being a team player
and that really is what makes a great
animal but like uh
animals
i mean i think it was just random like
like uh they got that with domesticated
dogs is like these people just started
fiend feeding these like [ __ ] wolves
yeah just randomly
and then they kept coming back and we
were just like okay maybe
you know
maybe i can [ __ ] him
maybe we can make him [ __ ]
this
wolf really likes the peanut butter
maybe i can spread it on my anus
that came a lot later
and then um
cats domesticated themselves yeah
they like they used to be like giant
and then
or the house cat
used to be like a giant cat and then it
kind of just like went smaller and
smaller
and like
so they were like oh the humans are
comfortable with me
thank god i've finally found the right
size
yeah and they like made baby sounds they
saw babies and i was caring for babies
so they like tried to replicate babies
they did they're like
they're like
oh that doesn't work
no that's not good
i can smell
the dudes getting hard women getting wet
when i make that sound
that's why they like milk so much
because they want to nurse at our teats
um
yeah
i think it would be cool to be a cat and
drink milk
cats are smart i feel like dogs try to
change themselves to make
us like them dogs are [ __ ] yeah but
cats
they try to change us to make us like
them
like
you gotta treat me like this
they're constantly like correcting us
they act like they're better than us
yeah they do and it's kind of annoying
you know
yeah they're like why shouldn't i pee on
your bed
that's obviously the right thing to do
and you're crazy for locking me out i'm
just gonna clean it up anyway
you're gonna get rid of my handiwork i
spent a lot of time
mixing that pee in my bladder
yeah
um
like spiders spiders like uh
are probably get so pissed when people
break their webs
because
um
you know they i don't know how long it
takes them
yeah and they have to make it
i was uh
i was vacuuming spiders at my work
because there's so many spiders outside
outside there's like so [ __ ] many and
they all have egg sacs
so they're all
producing so many babies
there's so many
and i'm vacuum up
spiders yeah and they're probably like
this guy has like a really strong web
because my web
it does the same thing it like traps
people in it but
i can move it around and suck things up
and like their web is like so industrial
like they have to wait for things to
come in
yeah they have to like wait and then
they get them but like my web it's a
proactive web my web is so much more
advanced than their web it's a non-lazy
web
and the funny thing is
i don't that's not even my main thing i
don't think about that
you know all they think about is webs
and they're like
i need to make my web this way this way
let's see i need to plan my web
vacuuming let's pick up a vacuum i have
the best weapon in the [ __ ] world
yeah you dominate their whole world and
you don't even care about it yeah it's
not i don't i i don't even think about
it you're like the michael jordan
of spiderwebs of the spider world except
you don't even
it's like a
hobby doing it
with me
but uh i mean if there's that many
spiders that means that there's that
many bugs
you what you should do is vacuum up all
the spiders and just go around vacuuming
up bugs
to feed him
and just have like a little colony i
could sell them
you'd be like come into spider world
spider king
i'll feed you
that could be spiderman
yeah
spiderman you know um
it's kind of weird
super power
webs
squirting it around like
other people have like you know flying
and
strength
lasers
like i got a web
i turned into a spider
it's like why don't you turn into
something with strength there's
definitely there's some superheroes that
are like you know
pretty pissed
about their powers
like [ __ ] superman thinks he's the
[ __ ] you know he has every power
like one guy just turns into a [ __ ]
wolf or
you know like a toad
like the toad guy um
what toad guy from x-men
there's a toad guy he can jump really
high and he has like a tongue
yeah and it's just like disgusting it's
not hot superman's hot
it's like the hottest power yeah
actually it makes you less
man you got blessed with not being hot
and you can't get any chicks with
with the toad powers
yeah when if you have a girlfriend
and then superman has a girlfriend
then um
your girlfriend is gonna be like uh i
really you really you have nothing
redeeming about you that superman
doesn't have like
i'm just settling for second best and
it's obvious and clear when we're in the
same room
and uh and batman and iron man don't
have any powers they're just rich
yeah
so unfair that's the american dream yeah
so like they get powers and they're rich
normally
thank god
that they exist
it's like us trying to justify how
wealthy some of some of us are like oh
look they could be like batman or tony
stark it isn't all bad look we can
imagine yeah you could be like that they
might be [ __ ] not evil
you could be like this you know and save
everyone even though you know it's just
like
like what are you even doing
yeah
um
i mean that's pretty cool that'd be cool
if like chad bezos did that
he's like i'm gonna
take out the taliban
in two days
i think he would get murdered by a man a
rocket
like hilarious
he goes there on the first day and he
just gets taken out yeah
someone get muhammad with the rockets i
am
package man
do i
push the
record
but uh i mean obviously
we can't rely on superheroes we should
instead each become superheroes
by giving ourselves the resources
in our world and together we are
better than any superhero
i am
dishwasher man
i uh if you actually were a dishwasher
man you you'd be so successful
why because there's so many dishwashers
if you could do it at like the speed of
you would save
money
yeah but like uh
you know i can i can make dishes
wash
but i do it at the same pace as someone
if someone just washed them
so i'm like i'm like washing it
it's just like okay you're still doing
you know it's the same thing you're just
doing it farther away
i can do it by concentrating
no i can do it i could just do it from
over here
yeah i mean it'd still be useful if you
can like you know
do your taxes at the same time
you do with your left hand and right
with your right hand you could do it
while you're eating dinner that'd be
useful yes
as soon as you're done you just start
washing
but maybe
but you have to like make noises and
concentrate really hard and like ruins
dinner for everyone else
oh you're really loud
someone turn off just
sure after dinner yeah we're trying to
rest that's louder than an actual
dishwasher
you're putting in too much
um i mean i think a dishwasher is a
great invention i don't know how it
works though you know well your
dishwasher doesn't work yeah it's [ __ ]
what do you mean it doesn't work like i
put it in i ran it and i think it still
came out dirty
so um
yeah i don't know how it works i don't i
mean i think it just works
by raining down water on all the dishes
in like a you know just in a linear
thing i don't think
you know maybe some modern ones come
from like all different directions yeah
i think that's the bottom
and it spins
it comes from the bottom i think so
maybe because yours doesn't have that
thing that sticks up in the middle so i
don't know how the bottom ones or the
top ones get washed
but uh i mean you can watch a youtube
video i think i did
and i think
maybe they like fill up the whole
dishwasher with water
no that's what i thought before but i
don't think that's true i think it's
just like
droplets of water yeah they spray it
down they hose it down and then they
soap up yeah but like things are like
blocking it you know it's just like the
bottom is blocking the top the dots on
the bottom i don't know how yours works
because like usually they in the old
ones they have the thing that sticks up
out of it
um
really in
yeah
but maybe you know it's like yeah i
don't know i don't trust it so modern
that it's
it can go around anything we should just
throw out
every dish and then just get new dishes
i know you should get paper dishes you
should just not use the top rack and
just use the bottom rack i mean we could
get compostable dishes up man
um thanks for watching we're talking
about your dishwasher
i mean you can it's not a big deal
exactly actually we'll probably keep it
in who gives a [ __ ] you know it's like
you didn't get to see our faces for
half a second i mean it's a surprise
it's an interesting you know
you know all of a sudden an event yeah
hey whoa where's this going
your roommate walks through
all that out and then just have this
part right here who who the [ __ ] are you
guys get out of
this podcast
ambush podcast today's podcast is
brought to you by random house around my
what is this for what is this guardian
exactly the poofiness the poofiness of
what of your air coming at the mic i do
have poofy air yeah you just poofed into
it
put it you got to put it in between you
yeah
like this yeah try poofing now it's just
like a
poof
it's not as percussive oh yeah that's
nice you know it's like a condom
hello
hey
it's like a bulletproof vest if you say
hey it doesn't really you can't really
see the bag
[Music]
i mean
um i don't like it you know i like i
like a
a real sharp
sound you like to rupture ear drums
anyone listening to this please don't
wear headphones what if we made a song
that could rupture ear drums
and we're like do not listen to this
yeah
do not turn it on at this volume
and be this close to it and then people
will be like dude have you heard the new
song it's like the most
extreme song ever it's gonna kill you
i mean um you can just listen to it at a
low volume
yeah but then people will be like i
listened to it on full volume it didn't
even hurt me man yeah bro listen to life
full volume last night like like three
hours nothing
there'd be like things like that where
you'd brag to your friends like in
elementary school and [ __ ] where you're
just like yeah i watched porn last night
yeah
like yeah
yeah you know like i stayed up late last
night you know
stayed up so late to like 11 a.m i hate
sugar
i ate marshmallows as long as i wanted
i told my mom she was a [ __ ]
if someone did that i'd be so jealous
if someone told their mom
right there a [ __ ] yeah they're like
whoa
oh i'm gonna do that
there'd be
you know that's not an uncommon thing
yeah in america such a [ __ ]
mom
i really wanted to
i don't know exercise agency and freedom
the thing is like uh you can't go
anywhere without your mom
like most moms all they do is ferry
their kids around in cars in america
yeah
so sad i love it
um yeah i mean but it would be it would
be like such a good feeling when you're
like
you know mom dropped you off
with your friends at like a mall or
something
yeah that place it's like the perfect
like i'm free yeah
and you're also loved three
you came with the blessings and safety
of your mother and all the money like i
know i have a ride at any time i could
just call
yeah i mean we need to get kids to uber
more
and your friends aren't as reliable as
your mom
yeah your friends are lame
no they're not lame they're
more fun seeking they're more like
dangerous they're more like exciting but
less
nurturing
they won't cook you macaroni and tell
you they love you they're incapable of
caring they care as much as they can but
it's not very much they only care about
breaking the rules
you're like uh
when you're like a preteen you're like
let's go break some rules
are there rules i want to break him
they're mischievous they want to rebel
against the system they find unjust
there's a lot of rules just right off
the bat don't do this don't do this
don't do this
yeah i mean it's not natural
i heard that focus on the things we can
do yeah we can you can sit in this class
jump you can leap you can soar you can
fly
maybe not fly or jump and leap
not if you're in a classroom
you can
listen and pay attention jumping is old
you're like you keep jumping you're like
okay what next
can we can we soar
can we not fly away
um
i mean
that's always been a joy or a fantasy of
humans to fly
to be able to fly but i feel like you
know
be so windy
you'd probably have to wear a helmet you
know it wouldn't be as cool as you think
it'd be rules and [ __ ] like
yeah
you'd probably have to wear like some
sort of suit
you'd have to turn on your transponder
and have the proper lights or you're
gonna get sucked up in a jet
yeah
and there's like bird [ __ ] in your face
and you know it's like cold
yeah right there
it's just wow
you fly through a cloud and
i would love that actually
i would love to just fly above the
clouds needles it's like sharp i know um
it would be amazing to fly i'd take
everything i said back be the [ __ ]
best yeah that's how we dreamed about it
that's why it's our dream to soar
through the skies
birds must have like a really
that must like be awesome dude like
walking is not fun but have you seen a
bird like a pigeon like how much they
have to flap their wings for them to get
off the ground like once you're off the
ground it's like sort of easy yeah but
gliding but like gliding though yeah
oh man
gliding bro
but you can do that with all that
equipment and all that like heavy [ __ ]
you're like holding on to it
and you got like that tarp or whatever
and you can do that thing where you
glide you know
you don't know that like with like the
wings it looks like uh oh yeah first
airplane yeah but it's so dangerous
because we're humans you know birds is
not dangerous for them yeah they can
gain altitude like with those gliders
yeah
overall on average you're going down
but like
walking isn't fun you know it's it's
unless you can catch an updraft but like
i saw a horse running on the beach
on reddit and it was like
so amazing how much
freedom it had it was just like playing
and then all of a sudden it was like
boom it just started running it it's
like that's [ __ ] crazy too like how
fast i can go
that would be freeing if you're a horse
and you could just like go 70 miles or
60 miles per hour yeah but it's it's
still not like gliding you know it's
like that's takes energy i mean you know
you're just chilling like it's you're
moving that's the perfect thing for you
yeah i would love that man so much
chilling out in this keep moving
but i love chilling
i have to move
you have to move to chill that's the
nature of humans
moving equals mc chill
chilling
equals um but and also like swimming you
know
for i saw duck the other day and it just
looks so
nice you know just to like be floating
on the water
yeah they're so light they're such light
creatures
yeah there's not no it's not like
like heavy
yeah
but then
when they're getting attacked by a fox
i bet they're like man i can't do
anything to it everything's so light
true true
i guess you know
everything has its flaws
yeah
but i think yeah i think ideally birds
because birds
the only thing that can
really kill birds is other birds or
animals on the ground
or fish
yeah
so birds you're fine unless you need to
eat pretty much
or drink
or drink or fly somewhere else like
birds like every time they go to the
ground it's like uh [ __ ] like imagine
every time you go to the grocery store
you have to like bring an ak
yeah or like i'll be back the zebras in
africa
how they have to go to the watering hole
because they're that thirsty but they
know there's a crocodile in there oh
yeah they're just drinking what was that
yeah that's annoying as [ __ ] i know
being that thirsty
yeah
like imagine after a workout when you
see that water fountain you're like oh
thank god but then there's like some
dude with like a like a sword
trying to [ __ ] clobber you going like
um
yeah man it's dangerous bro
yeah just a drink
but uh you know that's how they get you
they know you have to go eventually
wow
but um
they're waiting
yeah
so comedies
going good are you uh excited about
comedy or have you lost
interest i like it it's just like takes
so much energy out of me
ideally
i want to just be able to
go there
pretty much immediately go up and then
go home
and then go to somewhere else like i
don't like waiting around and like
talking to people it just like takes so
much [ __ ] work
yeah but do you think that other people
are like
oh
he's gonna try to talk to me
like do you think you're ever the person
that's
like
talking to other people who don't want
to be talked to
um definitely
so do you do that just because
it'll make your life more fun but you
know that they're not gonna really enjoy
it but you do it anyways because
it's the only way to make the weight
bearable for yourself
yeah i mean i guess it's just like uh if
there's a if there's someone i know
it just feels weird not to acknowledge
them and say hi
yeah
you know
it's like you hate them if you go in a
corner you're giving them the silent
treatment yeah and it's just like it's
it's just natural instinct to be like
you know
but update me you know what's what
what happened to you who are you what's
going on download the information give
me your latest captain's log
yeah
yeah you know
yeah i mean i think the weight is very
difficult
but there's always ways to be alone but
like if you want to be alone you sort of
have to be like grumpy and curmudgeonly
and then you have to turn into this
thing that you don't want to be
yeah
right yeah you know it's
i mean i do like talking to people
because it is boring just to not talk
yeah
um
but it's so difficult in comedy because
when you're talking to someone i'm like
what are they
trying to get from me and what do they
think about me do they think i'm funny
do they think i'm that's what you're
thinking
i don't know what i'm thinking
i just sometimes don't want to talk to
someone
and i'm like i'm just trying to like
do the bare minimum necessary but then
they're like oh you're being stupid
right now then i'm gonna
make you look stupid and do tricks over
you
because like intellectually they're more
engaged in the conversation so like
you're incentivized
to invest more energy into the
conversation or else you're going to
look stupid
um right
yeah you're like what's up with this guy
yeah i was talking to this guy and
it's [ __ ] weird
and also it's just like i see the same
people
every [ __ ] day and the energy gets
stale
yeah you're not excited
to talk to them anymore
um
not just that i'm not excited to [ __ ]
do stand up in front of the same people
yeah
that's why the best way to be a comedian
is to do shows
yeah that's uh that's my strategy
let's just do a lot of shows i don't
know why more people don't do it but i
found a little life hack
no i'm just kidding i don't i don't
really do that many shows i used to be
getting booked a lot but i guess i get
booked more than
i used to be so i should be happy
count your blessings
but um
yeah i mean shows are great but still
even shows are like that's like the true
comedy but there's different types of
shows and there's different levels of
shows
but i mean
there is yeah but like
any any show is going to be better than
a mic just solely due to the fact that
the audience doesn't know you and
haven't seen you before
yeah and there's like an energy of
people that actually want to be there
but sometimes that's not a good thing
like if you're doing a show in the
middle of nowhere and it's just like
these dumb [ __ ] idiots and they
they uh
you know they just want mindless fun and
you want to be doing like fancy art
comedy
um
yeah yeah
and then you're like oh this sucks i'd
rather be doing an open mic with my
friends who
understand what i'm saying
and have the same background as opposed
to these people i don't know much about
who i can only do fart jokes for because
that's the only thing we have in common
right yeah i can see that
but it's like you know
if um
if they don't appreciate their art
that's on them
yeah
do it for you
yeah
but i mean i think that uh you should uh
do more comedy
i know i really and that you're talented
and thank you you don't make any sense
outside of comedy
what do you mean
i mean you're bad at juice land
you're bad at
military you can't join the army why not
because
you just be standing there with your
mouth a
gateway what do i do
uh i could i think i'd be good at the
monkey bars
monkey bar to the taliban
um i could be a
riley get off the [ __ ] radio
where are they where are they
they're like
kind of
if do you see that cloud they're like
right under that cloud
what cloud there's clouds everywhere
this is a war zone yeah the one that
like you know you know which one i'm
talking about
it kind of looks like
a bunny rabbit
and a deer
oh
yeah i could be a chef a cook
you could be the slowest chef morning
jets here's your slap
something that requires low intensity
but like
a lot of creativity
um i could be
a
a disney
you could like write tweets
for someone
yeah it could be a tweet writer
it could be like you could be a street
street uh street fighter uh a painter of
the street uh lanes
i feel like you'd be good at that
painter oh
oh i know she went i've always wanted
i've always seen those guys i'm like
that looks
pretty fun
no it doesn't look fun but it looks like
really satisfying yeah
it's like you did that you can look back
and you're like whoa look at all these
perfectly symmetrical lines
yeah it's so white
so pure
but yeah something that you can do at
your own pace because i don't feel like
you'd be good at following a rigid pace
at all
yeah
um
[Music]
that'd be good snail
snail space
you'd be good at like proctoring an exam
or like
oh man dude i was always so jealous of
the proctors because i'm like they don't
even they can just be on their phones
they don't have to be taking the exam
right now but it's probably so boring
for them yeah i think that would suck
yeah i'd rather take the exam
yeah at least you're like doing yeah
doing something
yeah you're just watching trying to ruin
someone's academic career you're just
like scanning
i'm i [ __ ] get
you [ __ ] you you're not using a number
two pencil
[Laughter]
yeah i actually don't think you'd be
good at that because what pencil is not
number two be like this is all [ __ ]
man why are they making me do this to
make other people do other things
because you're very like
fairness based yeah
i would honestly just leave the room i'd
be like i trust you guys
i'm all about chill vibes
take as much time as you need
cheat
if you want
i would always ask that work together i
would always ask that in like high
school like whenever i took the quiz i
was like um they were like is there any
questions i was like yeah it's cheating
are we allowed to cheat oh that's so
situational i love class clown coffee
i'm so aware so you got to be so sick
up to the point where it's like almost a
burden yeah
um you're blessed with this burden
to mock
uh arbitrary i yeah and i did it in
college too i would just like
just
in like just destroy the class structure
just random
out loud thoughts and questions and just
like it was just like what like
it was just like everyone would just
like
you need to take a second to like get
back on track like after the thing i
said yeah
can you can we cheat
is cheating aloud
i would like
like in biology it was just like a
biology class like with like biology
majors and they were all super sciencey
and i asked like
can trees feel things like trees like
feel emotions you tell me this
that's so funny
can i feel what a tree is feeling
um i uh
[Music]
there was a kid that was like leaning
back in his chair and the teacher was
like
that's so dangerous don't do that and i
was like yeah lamarr don't be such a
daredevil
whoa
and everyone was like
it's so true it's not truly that
dangerous it's all about control
and then i was reading this passage
that i didn't want to read in english
classes like the dog went to the mall
and then and then one line was like
get your hands off my woman you [ __ ]
and i read that like super forcefully
then that was like a real big round of
applause
yeah i was in theater class and we'd
always read lines
and i was like i would do like funny
voices and stuff
it's so cool like yeah that like um
it's all about context
with classroom humor
like what do the people
around in the classroom think what is
going on is it a good thing or it's like
are we doing this for no reason it's
like if you do if you're if you're like
doing something actually important and
you try to like make fun of it they'll
be like no this is actually worth doing
it's like this is a part of our
education but if it's like some [ __ ]
that no one wants to do yeah and you
make fun of it then the audience will be
on your side yeah yeah cause like this
one time i went to a self-defense class
in college and i thought it would be
like actual self-defense but it was like
a rape like like how to like defend
against a rape yeah why would we teach
them that
counterparty there's
uh and it was just like all women and
like
you were there and i was there
and i because i thought it'd be actually
like useful
it was more just saying no in a loud
voice
and like we yeah we like christie
the teacher made us go around and punch
a bag and say and say no or stop
so [ __ ] dude
like it was like we had to punch it like
three times and like and as we were
punching we'd say stop
stop
stop
uh
and uh i mean i'm sure but like i i felt
bad because i was just making fun of it
the whole time
and but like the women in there were
just like probably like probably like
what the [ __ ] is this guy doing is he
raping us right now
they should have been to you when you
made a shitty joke stop learning
because i mean yeah that's like a good
lesson i think definitely yeah i was
like some people hassle about it some
people don't have that gear where they
can just
be like [ __ ] you i'm out of here like
they don't have that yeah so they're
just stuck but if you teach them like
you know little things like that then
they're gonna be like they can
work on the basic steps of like like you
know like rejecting what's going on
instead of just going along with
everything
it's so funny man
there's like so weird
i did a english presentation like on
some [ __ ] and on the end of it i had
like a tribute to biggie
like rest in peace biggie smalls
and that was like the last powerpoint
slide and i was like okay that's
conclusive
presentation and and then i put it up
that slide i was like any questions
what was it on it was like english like
probably like uh like
the invisible man like a book report or
something i don't remember
oh
oh [ __ ] your neighbor's here oh no
that's miles's car
um
but yeah school
but um
we gotta wrap it up
yeah
we could have gone for seven hours but
well you know i get uh
other
i gotta do a podcast in my mind
i gotta do a better podcast somewhere
else
um but yeah i mean thanks for letting me
stay here with all my stuff over here
and are you gonna make a podcast studio
in your room
yeah
we could have probably done it in there
i got to get a new [ __ ] uh
cover or i gotta wash my cover just wash
it yeah
um
and i gotta get a chair and a desk and
i've
been trying to get there for like
[ __ ]
two months i can get you chairs and
desks for free
and i can go in a nice chair and ask
look on craigslist and i'll send it i
did
i'll get one from paige because she said
that she had one for you right
chair
a table
yeah i need that one
have you seen it
no i mean yeah
okay i think
you want the anyways
but yeah i mean that that'll be nice
when you get that studio then we can
film podcasts there without having miles
and the dog in it
yeah you know
dog is just not good for podcasts
this is a podcasting duck he's fine i
mean it's honestly the prob the audience
probably enjoys like a little
interruption from our
boring
voices so cute
look at this dougie
do you want to say anything oh my god he
looks terrified
don't lick it
hello doggy
i can feel its heartbeat
so uh you know you went to the dog park
recently
have you smelled any interesting butts
dogs wouldn't
joy but they would enjoy
dog parks more but i don't think they
like it that much
i think it's stressful for them like
they have to go sniff butts it's like
they feel this compulsion
they're like oh [ __ ] i gotta go sniff
this guy's [ __ ]
it's like us at an open
yeah i just wanna hey gary
yes i'll sniff you
come on sniff me
i know you want to so we should get the
uh wife we could should get the wives
together this weekend go sniff in the
cabin somewhere
yeah that sounds great you chewing any
good bones recently
what the [ __ ] this dog's like resting on
all our podcasting equipment
absolutely expensive
stuff it's an expensive taste
my bed is just
my bed is your tools
anyways uh
thanks
for what
we're doing the podcast thank you for
doing the podcast
let's do the podcast let's put it on
spotify or something
i tried
i'll do it
it's like anchor it's like [ __ ] the
formatting is weird or something i can
just do audio only yeah do audio okay
did my alarm go off
we still have two minutes
sure
see you guys all right
bye